Unreal Engine 5's foliage tool can be used to paint mass amounts of static meshes across
your scene.
This tool will work on landscapes, static meshes, BSPs, transparent surfaces, and even
other foliage meshes.
That's right, you can get some foliage inception by painting your foliage on top of foliage.
Let's take a look at how this tool works by popping over to the editor now.
So for this tool to work, what we need to do first is come up to our selection and go
down to foliage.
And this is going to activate the tool.
Now across the top here we have our select all these select, select and valid, lasso,
paint, reapply, single fill, erase, remove, and move.
Out of all of these tools, the ones that you're probably going to be using the most are going
to be select.
What this does is this actually allows you to select individual foliage actors and then
adjust their properties.
The next one is going to be paint, as paint allows us to paint.
So let's go ahead and add something to this to see how this tool works.
So hitting control space, I have my static meshes selected.
I'm just going to grab this basic asset two and drop it right in there.
With that selected now, you're going to see there is my foliage brush.
And if I just left click, look at that.
So a couple of things that we can adjust here across the top, we have our brush size, which
allows us to increase the size of our brush.
Our paint density allows us to increase the density that things are going to be painted
at. I'm going to set that back to 0.5.
And then our erase density does the same thing.
It allows us to increase the density of the erase.
You can see here when I hold shift, that's how I'm actually erasing things right there.
Further on down here, what we have is the individual settings for our foliage actor.
So the painting controls how this is going to look when it is painted.
So we have our density here, which decreasing this, setting this to like one is going to
give us fewer.
And then setting this to something really high is going to give us a whole lot of them.
Radius is a really cool option.
So what radius does is it defines the minimum distance between the foliage actors so that
they don't collide with one another.
One way to figure out this number is if you double click on your static mesh here, and
under the approximate size, if you look at this middle number 104, we're going to close
that.
We're going to set our radius here to 104.
And this is a great way to figure out what a good size is going to be for your particular
mesh so that things do not intersect.
You can also use the bracket keys on your keyboard to make the brush smaller or larger.
And you can do this with actually all of the editors like the landscape editor.
If you need to adjust the size of your brush, we can also adjust the min and the max.
So set that to two.
One of the other things that we can do here under our placement is we have the ability
to adjust how our normals are, how this object is aligned to the normals of a surface.
And then we can even set things like the ground slope angle so that, for example, we could
have maybe a certain mesh that we want to use that can only be selector.
Maybe it only grows on a certain angle so that when we paint this particular thing across
our landscape, it will only go on areas that meet this particular criteria.
We can get actually very advanced in particular with the restrictions that we make with this
tool.
Underneath the instance settings, this is going to control how this reacts to things
like lighting and collision, which I highly recommend.
You do not put collision on your foliage objects.
It is just going to cause you problems.
We have a physics which will allow us to override our physical materials and scalability in
drawing in the virtual texture.
One of the other things that we can do with this tool is notice that there's a little
save icon right here.
We could actually save these settings to a specific thing called a foliage asset, which
will make it a lot easier when we need to apply this foliage to another level or we want
to use it in some other instance.
Now one of the other things that I want to show you here, let's click on select.
If I click select here, notice that I can select them.
If I hit the space bar, I can rotate it, I can scale it, and I can also delete it.
This is really great if you happen to paint a bunch of foliage and you realize it's going
through say a building or something, you can come in here and select or we could do like
a lasso selection and select a bunch of them and just remove the ones that happen to be
intersecting.
The other thing that I want to show you, and this will be the last one for this, is reapply.
What reapply does, let me just come here to paint really quick and let's paint a bunch
in here.
What reapply does is it allows you to reapply a setting without actually having to erase
everything and reapply everything manually.
What reapply does is if we come here and we go to, I don't know, placement, let's just
say like negative 50 by negative 125 and we'll just do like that.
That's probably a little bit too much.
So zero, the maximum could be like negative 50 and the minimum could be, for some reason
they're like linked.
I don't know what's up with that, but there we go.
Something like that.
So what this is doing is it's allowing us and we decide, you know what, I don't actually
want that at all.
So I want them to go back to the way that they were.
So there we go.
Now I've reapplied that particular setting without actually having to remove them.
So if we're really happy with our foliage, we can come in here to the reapply and just
adjust the parameter that we want.
We're also not limited to just one single foliage type.
I can do a bunch of different things.
Let me just come out here and not sure why they're not showing up for me.
Oh, because I'm in reapply.
Let me come over here to paint.
There we go.
That's the beginning, all of those individual little things sitting out here.
So there we go.
All right, so that's the foliage tool.